Is Holmes and Watson really that bad?
Apparently it is - since its Christmas Day
release, critics and audiences alike have
been teaming up to tear the project apart,
with even the rare good review still describing
considerable portions of the movie as "painful."
That's not how comedy is supposed to work.
Here's why Holmes and Watson bombed.
Whatever excitement there was for Holmes and
Watson was mostly due to the presence of its
two lead actors, John C. Reilly and Will Ferrell.
The comedic duo first came together in a big
way for the 2006, country-fried comedy Talladega
Nights: The Ballad of Ricky Bobby, a sendup
of NASCAR and southern-style culture that
brought in over $162 million at the global
box office and gifted pop culture with quotes
that have withstood the test of time.
“Shake and bake!”
“What does that do?
Does that blow your mind?
That.
Just.
Happened!”
That collaboration was followed in 2008 by
the even more enduringly-beloved Step Brothers,
which earned over $128 million globally.
“Did we just become best friends?”
“YUP!”
Though Reilly and Ferrell haven't gotten any
less funny over the years, their appeal as
a comedic duo managed to fail them with Holmes
and Watson.
A week after its release, the movie had only
earned around $24 million against an estimated
budget of at least $42 million - not exactly
the sign of a successful reunion.
“Oh!
Amazing!”
Notoriously low review scores weren't the
only bad press Holmes and Watson received
during its rollout.
The day after its theatrical release, Deadline
reported that the people responsible for Holmes
and Watson had actually tried to prevent the
movie from having a theatrical release at
all.
Instead, executives tried to pass it off to
Netflix in an effort to contain the damage
- an offer which Netflix obviously refused.
Reporter Anthony D'Alessandro wrote:
"[...] test scores for Holmes & Watson were
so bad that Sony tried unloading the movie
to Netflix, but the streamer wouldn't buy
it."
It’s important to keep in mind that Netflix
is the streaming platform responsible for
The Ridiculous 6 - a movie that has been consistent
in its zero percentage rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
It has been noted that the marketing campaign
for Holmes and Watson was curiously muted.
In fact, if not for the wickedly poor reception
the movie received, it's possible you never
would have heard of it.
When a studio is confident it has a hit on
its hands, like with Sony's own Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse, it tends to get the
word out early and promote the film as often
and widely as possible.
In the case of Holmes and Watson, Sony seemingly
threw it into the crowded holiday mix, crossed
some fingers, and hoped no one would get too
mad.
“Oooooh.”
“Are you quite sure this is a good idea?”
“This is fine!”
Holmes and Watson only managed to rake in
enough money to earn a number seven spot at
the domestic box office during its opening
weekend.
This placed the brand new release behind second
weekend performances of Aquaman, Mary Poppins
Returns, and Bumblebee, as well as the third
weekend runs of Spider-Verse and The Mule.
Holmes and Watson’s only saving grace would
be positive word-of-mouth, but even that seems
scarce.
“Mr. Holmes, the empire is depending on
you.”
Though fortunes have certainly turned for
movies with less-than-impressive debuts - such
as the remarkable run of 2017's The Greatest
Showman - Holmes and Watson seems to sorely
lack any crowd-pleasing qualities that could
redeem itself.
In short, Holmes and Watson failed at the
box office because it was a failure of a film.
Simply put, the so-called comedy couldn't
ignite the same passionate response as previous
collaborations between its capable leads,
resulting in an inability to attract audiences
in the middle of a crowded holiday season.
The broad critical consensus is that Holmes
and Watson is just not worth seeing, even
for curiosity's sake.
At its best, Holmes and Watson is on the same
level of quality as some of those “cut for
time” Saturday Night Live sketches - the
kind that didn’t make it into the actual
live broadcast for good reason.
The detective work here is simple elementary
- you’d be better off spending your money
on nachos.
“They got bottomless nachos at Bennigan’s.”
“Gah, a whole mess of nachos sounds good
right now.”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.